do you think looking at women you can
tell what a society looks like if you
want to see what a society looks like
you look like 100 you can look at
society and and that is why men are
flying over from the West to another
country and get in play the women from
this from the West they can't fly over
somewhere else to go again man no no
absolutely
I'm dealing with that if women cannot go
we don't have the same if if Western men
are not wanting us and can't deal with
us we can't get a man here men from more
traditional countries which the vast
majority of the other countries in the
world are way more traditional than the
West especially the U.S I don't know
about the UK but the the us if the men
there say that you're a hot mess and
they're not wifing you up you're not
going to go to Italy uh you know
Portugal or or Brazil and and get a man
unless he's trying to get a Visa